تجريد ايران من عضويه هيئه امميه تعنى
بحقوق المراه فقد تم تصويته بالموافقه على
القرار بسبب اتهامها بقمع الاحتجاجات التي
تتقدمها نساء وهو ما رات فيه واشنطن
اجماعا دوليا ضد طهران
اللجنه هيئه الامم المتحده الرئيسيه
المسؤوله عن تعزيز المساواه بين الجنسين
وتمكين المراه ولا يمكنها القيام بعملها
المهم اذا تم تقويدها من الداخل وجود
ايران في هذه اللحظه هو وصمه عار على
مستقيه اللجنه
29 عضوا في مجلس الامم المتحده الاقتصادي
والاجتماعي تايدا لطرد الجمهوريه
الاسلاميه من لجنه الامم المتحده المعنيه
بوضع المراه للفتره المتبقيه من تفويض
2000 2020 الى غايه 2026 كما صوتت ثمان
دول بالرفض بينما امتنعت 16 دوله عن
التصويت
بس هذا طلبه هو مجرد مثال صارخ اخر على
نفاق الولايات المتحده التي تملك تاريخا
من الاساءه الى المفاهيم والقيم مثل حقوق
الانسان من اجل تحقيق اهدافها السياسيه
غير المشروعه باستخدام منصات وموارد الامم
المتحده يقول اعضاء هيئه الامميه ان حكومه
ايران تطبق سياسات تتعارض بشكل صارخ مع
حقوق الانسان من خلال استخدام القوه
والقمع في حق متظاهرين السلميين خرجوا الى
الشوارع للاحتجاج بعد وفاه الشابه ماسا
امينه وتعلن الهيئه الدوليه الامميه حسنا
بتعزيز المساواه بين الجنسين وتمكين
المراه في ما اشار معارض ايران من بينهم
روسيا والصين الى ان طهران تخبت عضوا في
الهيئه وان اخراجها منها يمثل سابقه خطيره